bonsoir jeudi 1er octobre bienvenue dans
le journal préparé par la rédaction de
tv 78 voici les titres de l'actualité
locale
l événement se clôturait ce soir ito
know me revenait pour une quatrième
édition campus des mureaux un salon
dédié cette année à l'autonomie des
personnes âgées handicapées une société
du territoire saint quentinois travaille
justement sur cette thématique blue line
et a basé à elancourt son président est
notre invité emmanuel macron sera aux
mureaux demain le président de la
république viendra prononcer son
discours sur les dangers du séparatisme
pourquoi at il choisi de le faire depuis
la ville yvelinoise lui qui s'est rendu
déjà à trois reprises sur place éléments
de réponse et puis chaque mercredi des
hommes elle s'installe sur le parvis de
la mairie de magny les hameaux 3 food
trucks propose des produits laitiers
créole et de la rôtisserie une première
étape en vue peut-être de la création
d'un marché dans la commune un projet
dans les cartons depuis plusieurs années
alors que les derniers chiffres du coït
19 sont alarmants une bonne nouvelle
malgré tout les délais des résultats des
tests se réduisent enfin dans la région
c'est le syndicat des biologistes d'île
de france qui le confirme ils sont
désormais obtenu entre 24 et 60 heures
pour les personnes prioritaires de 4 à 6
jours pour les autres franciliens l2
explications avancées la priorisation
des patients et la capacité des tests
qui a été augmentée avec l'ouverture de
centres dédiés dans la région 13 sont
déjà opérationnels dont ceux de trappe
comme vous voyez à l'image est celui de
mantes-la-jolie les sept autres
devraient l'être dès lundi prochain
rappelons que le dépistage massif reste
l'une des stratégies phare pour endiguer
l'épidémie afin d'identifier et d'isoler
les cas positifs
[Musique]
pour la quatrième année consécutive le
salon hit only se tenait aux mureaux
deux jours d'événements autour des
innovations pour les personnes
dépendantes elles les professionnels du
secteur se sont retrouvés sur place le
reportage de bixente mariens insisté ban
et de patrick jacques de dixmude
organisé par la plateforme
départementale une vie le salon
autonomie a pour but de proposer des
solutions tourner vers l'avenir pour les
seniors ou les personnes en situation de
handicap
des conférences ainsi que de nombreux
stands étaient proposés durant les deux
jours de l'événement
on a créé le hub autonomie qui a pour
ambition développer un incubateur un
accélérateur de projets notamment
d'organiser le territoire
d'expérimentation et le département des
yvelines est le département des
hauts-de-seine qui sont les principaux
soutiens
il était important de travailler sur des
leviers pour améliorer les conditions de
travail des professionnels parmi les
exposants présents de nombreuses
entreprises yvelinoise qui cherche à
collaborer afin d'améliorer diversifier
leurs services l'idée là c'est de faire
un appartement immersif on va pouvoir
voir les différentes technologies qui
peuvent être adaptées au logement
alors il ya bien sûr notre télé
assistance de jarvis access mais vous
voyez il ya tout un tas d'autres
produits si de la vaisselle spécifique
pour les personnes
comment dire atteinte de parkinson on a
des tables qui peuvent s'ajuster en
termes de hauteur le but étant de
rapprocher cette technologie de les
mettre à disposition les patients et à
la disposition du corps médical afin que
lui-même puisse prolonger sa
bienveillance sur le patient des fois
même en dehors de l'hôpital ou de la
clinique
ouvert au public lors des éditions
précédentes li tonomy était cette année
réservé aux professionnels
la crise sanitaire a d'ailleurs impact
et certaines demandes on a aussi la
demande des fois départementale d'avoir
des technologies qui s'intègrent
beaucoup plus dans l'habitation du
patient lui-même afin d'avoir une
interaction à la fois être le monde
médical l'accompagnent ont bien sûr où
la famille un salon virtuel a aussi été
mise en place pour pouvoir assister aux
stands et aux conférences à distance
en cette période d'épidémie est avec moi
en plateau laurent levasseur bonsoir
bonsoir grégory vous êtes le président
et fondateur de blue line et est une
entreprise qui est basé à elancourt et
qui travaille justement sur les
thématiques de l'autonomie pour les
personnes âgées et handicapées déjà une
petite réaction au sujet que l'on vient
de voir est ce que la période actuelle
lyoko vie de 19 à à réactiver toutes les
réflexions est-ce qu'elle rend encore
plus primordial ses réflexions justement
autour d'eux des possibilités voilà de
rester chez soi voilà des possibilités
autour de l'autonomie des personnes
âgées et des personnes handicapées
filière de la perte d'autonomie des
personnes âgées s'appelle la silver
economy et évidemment
avec la crise qu'on vient de vivre sans
précédent tout ce qu'on pouvait dire sur
ces la filière du futur est devenu le
sujet du moment donc réfléchir à des
solutions peut-être que ça aussi suscité
des réflexions pour votre entreprise
cette cette période qui vient qui ce qui
se poursuit actuellement
alors là ça va pas rentrer dans six
minutes mettant des faits durant les six
derniers mois
on a pu comprendre plus que jamais le
rôle que nous avions pour les familles
prendre soin de leurs grands-parents à
distance 24 heures sur 24 qui soit à
domicile ou en ehpad
c'est loin d'être un sujet accessoires
et d'ailleurs on en parlait tout à
l'heure en préparant cette émission elle
il ya un sondage qui va sortir la
semaine prochaine sur sur une thématique
ont à dire lié liées à cette période
oui nos équipes en ce moment sont en
train de réaliser un sondage auprès de
plus de 1000 personnes âgées depuis plus
de 70 ans pour connaître quelle est leur
sentiment c'est à dire pendant le
confinement leur moral est aussi comment
ils vivent les nouvelles annonces de
cette fin de mois de septembre
et puis aussi leurs relations avec le
virus et leur relation avec leur
entourage
les premiers chiffres sont assez
intéressants car ils sont peut-être en
contradiction est ce qu'on imagine alors
deux chiffres 83% des français
souhaitent vieillir à domicile 12
millions de français qui sont touchés
par un handicap il ya vraiment des
besoins en la matière on a compris vous
développez d'ailleurs plusieurs
innovations à l'innovation c'est ça
ouvre le champ des possibles sur sur ces
thématiques
alors c'est de l'innovation des objets
connectés
d'accord mais pas seulement il ya
beaucoup d'intelligence humaine ça peut
faire sourire n'a pas que l'intelligence
artificielle
on a une plateforme à elancourt donc à
saint quentin qui suit à distance près
de 30000 personnes âgées chez elles et
puis on va aussi sur place de plus en
plus
tout à l'heure vous parliez du salon et
autonomie on a dans nos partenaires par
exemple les autonomies planner est une
équipe qui se déplace sur directement
auprès du domicile de ces personnes
âgées et qui va coordonner ce qui se
passe donc entre une plateforme à
distance des objets qui nous permet
d'être connecté et après une équipe qui
va être sur place on a tout un continuum
tout un accompagnement qui permet à des
personnes âgées d'être mieux accompagnée
avec surtout un chiffre important
l'insee a publié un chiffre il ya un an
297 km 2 197 km c'est la distance qu'il
ya entre des grands parents et des
parents donc c'est à l'échelle nationale
est assez important et avoir quelqu'un
qui a
300 km de distance en moyenne va prendre
soin de vos grands parents ce n'est pas
anodin mais vous lisez donc un continuum
des solutions innovantes de l'humain on
a compris une plateforme qui est
d'ailleurs basé à elancourt qui fait de
l'assistance de l'accompagnement 24
heures sur 24
oui durant d'ailleurs la crise du coc
vide on a vu une augmentation de
souscription en ligne sur notre site
internet les gens peuvent équiper leurs
parents c'est entre 19 et 24 euros par
mois suivant ce qu'ils aient pris un
bouton d'appel ou un détecteur de chute
et on les livre dès le lendemain on les
livre dès le lendemain matin dans toute
la france et ça permet comme ça
d'assurer une présence beaucoup de
réconfort 10 % des appels c'est
l'assistance pur et dur des chutes
détresse respiratoire des urgences
médicales 60% du temps c'est surtout du
réconfort des gens sentent un peu seuls
on parle avec eux et puis 30% du temps
c'est avec leur pain que on va pas que
leurs enfants
on va parler ils nous demandent comment
se comporter avec leur maman
parkinsonienne avec un papa alzheimer ou
tout simplement comment gérer telle ou
telle situation quand ils sont à
distance est chez nous on adore parce
que ça rend ça donne du sens à notre
équipage 24 et c'est ainsi qu'on sort
cette services qu'on appelle le service
help
il ya des solutions par exemple on en
avait parlé un déjà sur ce plateau une
montre qui vous géolocaliser qui permet
à des personnes souffrant d'alzheimer
voilà de pouvoir alerter avec avec cette
montre géolocalisant tu pour le handicap
blue line a trahi plutôt sur
l'adaptation des des lieux de vie c'est
ça avec notamment des solutions de
domotique tout à fait sur le handicap on
va chercher à adapter le lieu de vie la
maison appartement
les volets roulants la porte des
éclairages aussi comment permettre à une
personne en situation de handicap très
âgés ou tout simplement à suite à un
accident de la vie changer les chaînes
de sa télévision se déplacer dans notre
fixe en a même sorti une solution qui a
été une idée de mon équipe j'ai beaucoup
de chance avec cette équipe
ils ont créé un joystick qui s'adapte
sur des playstation sur des switchs
comme ça
une personne associée handicap peut
jouer à des jeux
de plus classique avec ses amis qui sont
pas nécessairement sur son handicap ça
recrée du lien et sa retrait de la vie
surtout souhaité qu'on voit actuellement
à l'image qui se pilote grâce au souffle
et ce qu'il ya de nouveaux outils sur
lesquels vous travaillez c'est un
travail de recherche tout le temps pour
proposer de nouvelles solutions va
écouter on est à quelques jours de
lancer le service help
c'est l'appellation la nouvelle
appellation de notre bouton d'appel de
notre détecteur de chute de notre
bracelet pour personne de localisation
pour les personnels zai moeurs help un
service compréhensible les gens
comprennent vite ce que c'est et on va
pouvoir mettre ça en place avec encore
plus cet accompagnement humain connectés
donc c'est l'air du temps et surtout ça
permet d'être connecté à une famille
tout entière donner les nouvelles à des
enfants pour ce qui se passe pour leurs
grands parents c'est pas anodin compris
voilà tout tout doit être connectée mais
avec l'humain sas et c'est essentiel
merci laurent levasseur d'être venu sur
ce plateau
merci garderie pour ça va très vite à
sion président et fondateur de bruni
n'est acquis et basé à elancourt
[Musique]
dans l'actualité également sans surprise
gérard larcher a été réélu aujourd'hui
président du sénat le sénateur des
yvelines et ancien maire de rambouillet
a recueilli 231 une voix dès le premier
tour loin devant le socialiste patrick
kanner qui récoltent 65 suffrages et la
communiste
eliane assassi qui totalise 14 bulletins
les parlementaires étaient appelés
aujourd'hui à élire leur président après
les sénatoriales de dimanche qui ont
conforté le poids des républicains au
sein de la haute chambre il s'agit du
quatrième mandat à la tête du sénat pour
gérard larcher dans l'actualité aussi la
venue d'emmanuel macro aux mureaux le
président de la république il sera à
demain pour faire son discours sur les
dangers du séparatisme il va détailler
ainsi à son plan de lutte contre l'islam
politique et le communautarisme ce sera
déjà le quatrième déplacement dans la
ville yvelinoise pour le président de la
république en cinq ans eléonore sinoquet
revient sur ses différents déplacements
les mureaux un choix qui ne doit rien au
hasard si emmanuel macron a décidé de
s'y rendre vendredi c'est qu'il connaît
bien la ville
c'est en tant que ministre de l'économie
qu'il a visités en 2015 une entreprise
spécialisée dans l'impression 3d puis
candidat à l'élection présidentielle en
il s'y était rendu pour rencontrer des
jeunes talents issus des quartiers
populaires de la ville président il y a
enfin effectué un déplacement sur
l'accès à la culture en février 2018
outre les multiples visites du chef de
l'état aux mureaux la ville a aussi
accueilli en décembre 2019
l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner il avait d'ailleurs
cité les mureaux comme exemple dans la
lutte contre le repli communautaire et
l'islamisme peut-être l'une des raisons
du chef de l'état de prononcer son
discours sur les séparatismes aux
mureaux la création pour les
associations d'un contrat d'engagement
sur la laïcité ou encore la pénalisation
des certificat de virginité
ces mesures devraient faire partie du
futur projet de loi
elle viendrait s'ajouter à la fermeture
de lieux où l'on prêche la
radicalisation et à la création des
quartiers de reconquête républicaine des
actions mises en place au début de son
quinquennat
elle a débuté en septembre et se
poursuit en ce début du mois d'octobre
la rentrée universitaire a concerné rien
qu'à saint quentin en yvelines à
l'université versailles saint quentin
vingt mille étudiants une rentrée dif
cl pour les universités au vu du
contexte est aussi avec une plus grande
précarité étudiante en conséquence la
région ile de france a lancé un plan
d'urgence dont elle a détaillé les
contours aujourd'hui plusieurs mesures
qui vont s'afficher notamment autour du
pouvoir d'achat et de la continuité
pédagogique un masque lavables sera
remis à chaque étudiant francilien soit
650 mille masques distribués au total
elle est bachelier boursiers étudiants
précarité de recevront 100 euros en
chèques numérique la collectivité va
également faire le don de dix mille
ordinateurs portables pour assurer la
continuité pédagogique en cas de
nouvelles fermetures des établissements
tout un volet également sanitaire trois
campagnes de dépistage aux colis 19 sont
prévues dans chaque établissement la
région pourra d'ailleurs financer ses
campagnes à hauteur de 20 mille euros
maximum par établissement dont de 50
mille tests virologiques et enfin
l'ouverture d'une centrale d'achat pour
faciliter les commandes de masques et de
produits d'hygiène pour le personnel des
universités
un salon pour les professionnels du
bâtiment tech bat se dérouler ce jeudi à
la ferme du manet de montigny le
bretonneux l'occasion pour nous est
d'échanger autour de la situation
actuelle des difficultés du secteur
aussi dans les yvelines et aussi sur les
perspectives
interview express mené par astrid
bergère
[Musique]
on a vidé et des partenaires à des 100
gratuitement spécifiquement nos
adhérents cette année on a quatre en
boîte à 48 exposants dans toute visée
toujours les matériaux nouveaux
on les fait ce que les gens connaissent
est intéressant ce qu'on veut c'est que
nos adhérents viennent pour le savoir
qu'est-ce qui s'est de nouveau il
commença et de demain
il ya eu un gros frein parce que là-bas
avec le comique bien sûr les gens qui
avaient fait des êtres avoir faire ne
faut pas rester sans vouloir les faire
mais là la culture les freiner dans leur
décision
suite à leur sort du confinement il ya
une grosse demande une très grosse
novembre 2007 en est là on fera un total
depuis quatre jours sans doute suite au
gouvernement qui prend des décisions
le profil mans a fait que les gens qui
avaient un petit à petit un petit chez
soir ils étaient puis un veau qui jardin
c'était beaucoup mieux
donc ils sont dix se sentent un peu
intéressé pour améliorer leur bien-être
est-ce que l'on revient confiné et quand
on est confiné d'un bien d'un chez soi
qu est sympa c'est quand même beaucoup
mieux
la quiétude de demain parce que je pense
qu'il ya un mode de vie qui va changer
depuis un mois ils occupent la place de
l'hôtel de ville de magny les hameaux
des food truck s'y installent désormais
tous les mercredis une première étape
qui s'inscrit qui s'inscrit dans une
volonté de la commune de créer un marché
depuis plusieurs années dans la commune
les précisions d'astrid bergère
les années passent et toujours pas de
marché à magny les hameaux néanmoins
depuis un mois les habitants peuvent
profiter de la rôtisserie la fromagerie
et des spécialités antillaises qui
prennent place chaque mercredi sur la
place de l'hôtel de ville et le
confinement il est pour quelque chose
cependant le confinement il se trouve
que sur les réseaux sociaux on aperçoit
une fromagerie qui avec la fermeture des
marchés fait de la vente et la livraison
sur la commune de magny les hameaux jeu
discutent directement avec elle
et je lui explique tout simplement que
on cherche à proposer à des commerçants
à des commerçants autonome de pouvoir
s'installer à magny les hameaux pour
pouvoir créer un un premier lieu de
vente ambulants les responsables de la
fromagerie accepte et c'est parti info
de trucs de spécialités antillaises
rejoint le projet ainsi qu une
rôtisserie lapereaux majeurs juste à
côté de nous on fait des marchés
ensemble le vendredi à vélizy donc elle
nous a proposé
on a dit allez on va essayer puis d'un
coup comme je vous dis on aime bien le
cadre des gens sont sympas ils viennent
nous voir ce sans difficulté il parle
avec nous et on a dit allez on continue
les vents ne fonctionne bien cette offre
qui s'ajoutent à celles des supermarchés
et commerces du centre ville séduit
largement les habitants est ce qu'on a
vu sur facebook la publication de la
ville
foutraque maintenant le mercredi donc
voilà on émouvoir la première fois mais
maintenant on vient tous les mercredis
la commune espère voir arriver d'autres
food truck elle invite toutes personnes
intéressées à se manifester
le sport avec la préparation des jeux
olympiques 2024 de paris une nouvelle
carte a été validé hier mercredi par le
conseil d'administration l'objectif
faire 400 millions d'euros d'économies
pour s'en tenir au budget initial fixé à
3,8 milliards d'euros si la seine saint
denis semble la grande perdante de ces
modifications
elle les yvelines serait préservée
d'après une information de tv 60,18 la
colline d'elancourt accueillerait bien
les épreuves de vtt et le bmx pour les
courses resterait aussi à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
le bmx freestyle irait lui place de la
concorde à paris pour rappel les
épreuves de cyclisme sur piste de golf
et d'équitation devrait avoir lieu
également dans le département cette
nouvelle carte non définitive sera
entériné le 17 décembre prochain
ce week-end on joue le 4e tour de la
coupe de france de football et 8 club
yvelinois seront engagés sur les
terrains à noter l'entrée des clubs de
national de versailles ira défier le
club du plessis robinson dans les
hauts-de-seine poissy se déplacera dans
le val d'oise à saint brice à suivre
également le déplacement de trappes à la
garenne colombes qui évolue une division
au-dessus des yvelinois et le petit
poucet qui tentera l'exploit à domicile
contre sainte-geneviève ses épaules ce
petit poucet sainte geneviève des bois
évolue
cinq divisions au dessus de l'équipe
yvelinoise les matchs sont à suivre ce
dimanche et aussi samedi pour trappe
c'est à 14h30 ou 15 heures une chance
bonne chance à nos club yvelinois et
pour refermer ce journal il ne vous
reste plus que quelques jours pour aller
écouter le brame du cerf le parc
animalier forestier de l'espace
rambouillet propose de découvrir ce son
si particulier et mais immersion avec
célia gars tsongo eléonore sinoquet
voici le brame le cri caractéristiques
du cerf entre la mi août et la mi
octobre
c'est la période de reproduction du roi
de la forêt pour impressionner les
biches et de façon à repousser les
autres mâles lecerf pousse son brame
pour pouvoir transmettre ces gemmes à
l'espace rambouillet où la grande faune
forestière gambade dans les 180 hectares
de forêt faire entendre ce phénomène
naturel aux visiteurs est un moyen de
faire de la pédagogie tout le plaisir
que des gens vont prendre ici on espère
que c'est du plaisir qu'ils vont à
prayssas répercuter sur tous les milieux
naturels qu'ils iront voir après ça va d
inciter à sortir à venir dans les forêts
et à venir dans avec beaucoup de respect
en fait par rapport au milieu naturel
pour répondre à cet objectif le parc
animalier et forestier géré par l'office
national des forêts organise d'ailleurs
des animations dont le matin ou assez
tard le soir pendant toute la période du
brame un guide accompagne les curieux
pour aller au plus près des animaux mais
le parc est aussi ouvert toute la
journée pour qui souhaiterait partir en
quête de ce son si particulier
l'idée c'est de prendre l'air voilà
moi je ne connaissais pas l'espace
rambouillet donc ça me permet aussi de
découvrir
et puis parce que la période des brames
dessert donc c'est vraiment voilà mais
on y venait pour sa ba un peu tous les
éléments les sangliers et j'en ai déjà
vu ba des bébés et pourquoi pas des
siens les visiteurs qui auront eu la
chance ou non d'entendre le brame
pourront dans tous les cas venir à
l'espace rambouillet observer les
naissances issues de cette période de
reproduction
les petits faons devrait naître en mai
ou juin prochain dans un instant sur tv
60,18 vous avez rendez vous avec le 7-8
loisirs et s'est présentée par vous
c'est agathe saint gobain soir mansart
êtes à la tête de l'émission depuis le
début de saison alors quelles idées de
sorties avez vous sélectionné pour nous
ce soir
eh bien d'abord on a testé pour vous le
body karaté un mélange de karaté et de
danse qui se pratique au gymnase du
vieux moulin à rambouillet ensuite ce
week end il y aura la 27e édition de la
fête du miel qui revient à plaisir au
programme donc des ateliers découvertes
et des produits du terroir
et puis enfin on ira au cinéma pour
parler du film en toilettes dans les
cévennes
il s'était retrouvé dans un instant
c'est à partir de 18h30 sur tv 60,18
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité
belle soirée à tous
[Musique]